there may be a new clue for doctors
trying to diagnose the corona virus some
patients say they lost their sense of
smell and taste 33 year old Jason Noll
has the virus and told us this is what
happened to him I lost my sense of smell
and taste a few days into my symptoms
honestly I didn't realize it at first I
got you know the flu or a cold and so I
felt like maybe I just was stuffed up
and I couldn't taste very well and then
it was I was adding cayenne pepper to a
dish that I was eating and I realized
that all I could taste was the eat I
couldn't taste the actual pepper I was a
little bit scared honestly like you know
is this permanent I don't know you know
nobody really knows nul says he's
recovering and slowly getting his senses
back after dr. Jon LaPook joins us now
from from his New York home John good
morning what more do we know about these
what more do we know about these new
possible symptoms well you know it's
been fairly common we're hearing it on
and off over the last couple of weeks
that people can have this transient well
this loss of cell of smell and the
question is how long does it last so I
reached out to some ent people last
night and they said yeah you know
they've seen this with other boroughs /
Tory infections and it can be transient
but in some people it can be
long-lasting or in some people it
doesn't come back so right now this is
all new and we don't know if it's true
for this new type of corona virus but I
know people are concerned about it but
for now it's a clue because if that's
the only symptom that you have it's it's
a clue to say maybe I well not maybe I
should sell quarantine because this
could be the only symptom and it's not
of the kovat set of the Cova 19 and it's
not a very common symptom right so I
think if you lose your sense of smell
that's something that you should tell
your healthcare provider about and you
should self isolate you should self
quarantine yeah fever is the one you
really should be looking for that's it's
very common but gastrointestinal
symptoms is something else we're hearing
about I think that means different
things to different people so what
should they be looking for in that
context well this is right up my alley
I'm a gastroenterologist and there was a
study of
200 people out of whom a China and about
almost 50% had some GI symptom but about
80% of that was loss of appetite that's
a little nonspecific but 17% 1 7% had
diarrhea and the diarrhea could be a
prodrome it could happen a couple of
days before you have the other symptoms
so it could be the only symptom and
that's something for people to to watch
out for now much smaller percent 2
percent had vomited a 1% had abdominal
pain but it's the diarrhea that's it's a
new symptom this is a new disease to us
and we're finding things out all the
time John the other day the World Health
Organization the whu-oh said that 80% of
the people have mild symptoms number 1
what does that mean exactly and if you
have mild symptoms what should you do
well mild symptoms this time of year
when you have flu season allergy season
cold season it's anything from just mild
sniffles a little bit of fever a cough
sore throat now we're hearing diarrhea
these are things that people get and
they think what is it kovat 19 or is it
just something that I've had in past
years and so I think what people are
saying to do now is unless you have
severe symptoms is that the severe
symptoms being fever shortness of breath
along with the cough or and you just not
maybe you're just feeling lousy or and
lousy and lousy oh those are symptoms
that you you reach out to your
healthcare provider and you you try to
figure out how to get in to see somebody
but if you're having these other
symptoms everybody wants you to stay
home because the last thing we want you
to do is come into a hospital
unannounced or a doctor's office
unannounced and spread kovat 19 to other
people so if you do have these symptoms
that you think that you may be having
kovat 19 call somebody whether it's the
your health care provider you don't have
that call a hotline a lot of the state
departments have it or call the
emergency room and get some advice from
a distance telemedicine or just on the
phone all right Jon LaPook I'm so glad
to see you I'm glad that you moved the
shot a little I was watching you
yesterday on Nora show and all I saw was
the O in the end I thought what does
that say behind him now I see it says
office that makes perfect sense to me
people learning more and more about us
yeah there you go
Thank You Jon LaPook